what you're about to see is so
insufferable so cringy you might not
make it through this whole video so just
fair warning if you have to just tap out
in the middle of this say Steven I can't
make it all the way through don't worry
I understand
because even writing this even going
through this even researching it I was
suffering to bring you guys this grade-a
cringe cauldron which you're about to
bear witness to so so with that little
disclaimer out of the way i absolve you
if you have to click off believe me I
understand but today we're going to be
covering the inseparable life of an
Instagram rich kid the rich kid in this
case being Evan Luthra and it's the
first of a multi-part fake guru about
this self-proclaimed multi-millionaire a
tech entrepreneur he says he has a PhD
in blockchain and he says he was
mentored by Steve Jobs
none of this than Steve Jobs and don't
forget about the fact that he's only 25
years old you know PhD at
multi-millionaire tech entrepreneur
mentioned by Steve Jobs Tech 25 years
old no big deal number two and we're
about to be going through one of the
these PR posts that he got written about
him by vice vice of all people I mean
honestly I expected this of Forbes I see
every single on so-called entrepreneur
make money online guy in featured in
Forbes but I did not expect this from
vice it's a sponsored post by Vice it's
called what do we own yachts and lobster
in Ibiza with tech millionaire Evan
Lutheran which already we're off to a
bang yachts and lobsters baby frankly
I'm disappointed in you vice I thought
better when I saw your post about London
real I saw a ray of sunshine but this
may have destroyed all of it so we're
gonna go through this together don't
worry I'm gonna walk you through it all
put on your seat belt buckle up here
boys oh I probably should introduce Evan
though real quick Evan he's mostly known
on Instagram where he has half a million
followers he's known for his money girls
like lifestyle style Instagram thing
which would be just as pathetic as every
other Instagram rich kid except the fact
that he goes one step further and tries
to be the tech investor right he
the claim he's mentored by Steve Jobs
billionaire Steve Jobs and he has other
outlandish claims like like developing
his first smartphone app when he's 12 at
the age of 12 he devised his first
smartphone app the only problem there
being that the app store wasn't launched
until he was 13 years old
so small problem there but but let's
just get into this post specifically so
starting off we have 21 year old startup
multi-millionaire Evan Luthor began
creating apps early on just after their
Apple inspired conception actually he
started before right because he started
when he was 12 which is before their
Apple inspired conception but the late
Steve Jobs the godfather of text
Transfiguration became Lutheran mentor
quickly recognizing his potential for
innovative unparalleled progression in
the laterally minded young business dude
he got like a bullet surprise with her
to write this stuff this is amazing the
unparalleled progression in the
laterally minded young business brain
aka yeah the young idiot because let's
let's be clear Steve Jobs RFP he died in
2011 so Steve Jobs died when this guy
was 16 he couldn't have mentored him for
very long I mean this guy was barely out
of the the diapers you know when when
Steve Jobs was no longer able to mentor
him so I don't know what kind of
laterally minded young business brain
Steve Jobs was looking for I would say
child labor laws at some point you know
come into effect you're 16 years old
Jobs is putting you to work dude no way
but then it gets better Steve Jobs
approached Evan to work out how to
harness the power of the newly
configured app store that's right even
though it says that you know Steve Jobs
was Luthor's mentor very quickly we
realized that there may have been a
different arrangement involved actually
Steve Jobs approached em and Lutheran to
work out how to how to harness the power
of the app store isn't that amazing
you know Steve Jobs was just racking his
brain you know how do I figure out my
app store my app store you know it I
don't know if it's gonna work who should
we call
how does it I know get get everything
Luther on the phone he's gonna know how
to harness the power of my newly
configured app store then we have a
little quote from Lothrop pontificating
on why steve invested in them I think
the biggest reason Steve invested in me
was because I was very young and he
appreciated that yeah you know Steve he
really really enjoyed spending the last
years of his life
investing in 14 to 16 year olds when he
and I first spoke on the phone it was
very very early days he had just built
the App Store and nobody was using it
yeah you guys remember that days when
nobody was using the App Store we all
remember those dark times before Evan
stepped in Steve Jobs he was just
looking for feedback according to good
faith like poor Steve you know he's
rolling in his grave here you know he
just wants peace gosh he revolutionized
everyone's life he just wants peace and
this guy's digging up the grave to pull
a little cloud out of it it's horrible
the poor man can't defend himself Steve
Jobs was just looking for feedback on
his app store that nobody was using it's
a great platform the conversation of
Legends right there you know young Evan
here which if it was 2008 when the App
Store first launched Evan was like 12 or
13 years old so Young Evans like great
platform mr. Jobs and Steve is like hey
but-but-but Evan nobody's using it how
do i how do I make it better it's a
really good problem Steve Jobs and Evan
Lutheran were like this guy's little do
you know and here we have our first
featured pic of Evan you know this is
the guy that Steve Jobs would be very
proud of right now they're they were
close they were close
really I mean was Steve Evans mentor or
was Evans Steve's mentor it's on it's
unclear because you guys know the
unparalleled progression of a laterally
minded young business brain it's
seriously it's it's no joke and Steve
Jobs recognized that he really wanted to
get Evans insight really really this is
great
vice I'm really happy you printed this
by the way guys we're two paragraphs in
have you cringed yet featured on
tumblers rich kids of Instagram
earlier this year lutheran is Facebook
famous for his excessive and exuberant
lifestyle filtered down his
billion-dollar ball and Social Feeds
know how much you paid to have that that
those words billion-dollar ball in
Social Feeds oh man I hope this writer
got a lot of money for this billion
dollar ballin Social Feeds well if
anybody if any of you out there ever
write anything about me and no I don't
have any money to pay you please write
down something about my billion dollar
ball and Social Feeds recently
instagramming too we got everyone
instagramming two pairs of Louboutin
studied at trainers Luther a purchase
the five thousand pound in both colors
because he couldn't decide on what she
preferred yeah real problems that said
through our conversation he impresses me
that experiences over possessions are
his most prized investments gosh this is
such a terrible puff piece if you told
the next generation you're never going
to be a millionaire they won't become
sad but if you told them you have to
live in one country for the rest of your
life and you can't move from this city
they would kill themselves is that even
true I mean do people really care that
much that much about traveling over like
wealth I feel like a lot of people are
trying to become rich oh and here we get
our first look at our author here she
looks absolutely thrilled to be covering
Evan Luther is billion dollar ball and
Social Feeds
speaking of billion dollar ball in
social fees he doesn't keep his partying
lifestyle separate from his business
affairs either the ponytailed party goer
infamously signs virtual contracts when
he's drunk on super club
what he signs virtual contracts when
he's drunk on super club dance which
that is not a good business decision
you're signing contracts when you're
drunk
I can't imagine something less advisable
wait what's going on I'm just gonna sign
this billion-dollar deal while I'm
partying on a super super clip what's a
super club by the way maybe I'm just not
a billion dollar balling enough to
notice of a super Club dancefloor is but
is this supposed to make this guy look
good this is making him look like a
reckless drunk you're signing contracts
while you're drunk on dant dance club
and also you're dancing and signing how
are you even reading them you're like
hey guys
[Music]
I don't know who's falling for this
who's falling for stuff honestly who
sees this and says wow that's that
that's pretty billion-dollar ballin I
want to sign checks on a super Club
dance floor it doesn't make any sense
preferring to take risks when his
confidence is vodka tinged his work
ethos embraces the lessons failure in
parts what again is this supposed to
make him look good yeah I kind of prefer
to do most of my investing when I'm
completely hammered but then you know
what the writer anticipates
that there she's gonna get some haters
from this so she heads us off at the
pass jealousy gossip and come downs
however are just minors in these boss
men's lives
Oh guys honestly this stuff is so
amazing and I love the writing I really
do love the writing a lot of effort you
could tell was put into this look at
this to make this guy look good this is
like some New York Times stuff where
religion may have dictated a life path
for the generation before him Evan
chooses his own spiritual high road
reading code not Scriptures likes are
the new tinder and if your account isn't
constantly being commented upon and rege
rammed by the masses then no amount of
money can make you interesting or
relevant evan is the next age
heartbreaker raising the bar for his
contemporaries a six-pack is so 90s and
this is my favorite part tomorrow's
children desire six figures social
followings and Evans accounts
truly this article sets a new standard
for journalism it will be studied for
generation guys look at this photo of
the author with evan luther ax this is a
girl who is jealous whose meyer and
those those six figures social-media
followings and that's pretty much all i
have to say about this this is the
article i wanted to cover today just to
wrap up I just want to say that we'll be
continuing our investigation into Evan
Luthra and some of his shady are doing
with this alleged scam system that he
had going on for a while there I'm
working with baller Buster's to uncover
a lot of that stuff so a big shout out
to him I'll leave a link to his
Instagram in the description box below
you don't know baller Buster's is
basically what I do but they do it on
Instagram and they have they have a
great track record of busting people
like Evan and exposing them for what
they actually do so go ahead give them a
follow and last but not least of course
we can't forget don't forget to smash
like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
for the car
[Music]